[Musique]
bassem garder la tête froide et j'adore
je crois que charlie sheen a dansé
retire parce que ça dort pas simple
consiste à conakry donc la nuit tout le
monde et tout le monde est là et tu peux
rentrer dans n'importe quel port les
gens se séparent
c'est un quartier animé donc je pense
qu'ils ont choisi le meilleur courtier
pour pour le festival
[Musique]
le quartier de la fête à paris
quartier un coup de chaud aussi
[Musique]
vraiment un quartier qui captive
colonnes du times un gain symbolique de
le faire là il se trouve qu'en plus ce
quartier aux concerts et spectacles on
découvre toute cette histoire de pigalle
cette foule cherche une écoute les gens
moins atypique
c'est un quartier qui est qu'il est
d'être d'être mieux vaut du n'est pas
seulement sous l'angle tout et fricker
reconnaître comme un peu peu à travers
sa population et à travers cet état
d'esprit double diffuseur quartier a
mené jusqu'au chine
[Musique]